- [Interviewer] Hector.
Hector,
where are you from originally?
- El Salvador.
- [Interviewer] El Salvador?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family.
Did you have both of
your parents growing up?
- My father passed away
when I was one years old,
and I grew up with my
mother and grandmother.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And
how was your childhood?
- How was, the what?
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
- I was sick,
I will have asthma for 18 or 20 years.
Yeah.
Anyway, I came to the United States,
I started to
work out
and
lose weight and
then my asthma disappeared,
99%.
- [Interviewer] Oh, so you're much better.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
And so you came to the U.S. at what age?
- Age, 28.
- [Interviewer] 28?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And what
do you do for living now?
- Actually, I delivery Domino's pizza.
- [Interviewer] You're on pizza delivery?
- Yeah, pizza or Pizza Hut. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Okay. Excellent.
- Right.
- [Interviewer] And, do
you have wife or children?
Do you have family?
- I have one children. I
think he's 14 years old,
but have to do a DNA test.
- [Interviewer] Oh, so
you're not sure then.
- I'm sure that he is my, but I
told her that had to do DNA,
to make sure that he's my son.
- [Interviewer] So you still
have not done that yet?
- I don't know yet.
- [Interviewer] You don't know yet?
- Yeah.
- By the forehead look like me.
(interviewer laughs)
- [Interviewer] Okay.
And, so,
you like to come down here
and pick up some of the
girls on the street?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] How often do
you come down here to do that?
- Like a twice a week.
- [Interviewer] Twice a week?
- Yeah. And I do it for pleasure.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. Of course.
How often have you been doing this?
- For 14 years, 15 years.
- [Interviewer] Hmm.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And do you find those,
relationships,
satisfy you, and they're fun?
- Yes they're fine.
- [Interviewer] And the
girls are nice to you?
- Yeah nice to me.
- [Interviewer] How do you treat them?
I mean, are you, someone,
I hear terrible stories
about some guys getting
violent and rough and all that.
- Yeah. One time I was with a girl,
you know, I can't remember her name,
but she was like freezing,
it was like raining,
she had little pimples in the face.
And I told what, my friend, she wait
inside the car and she told
me, let's go to the corner.
And she was with me, and two guys came,
you know
like a walking and she opened
the doors, the back door.
And then when he sat in the car,
and one of them he went outside,
and he put me a gun on the mirror.
On the window right here.
He put me a gun.
And he told me, you know.
I give everything that I
have, we can give it $10.
She went outside too.
And I gave like, all my money that I have.
But nothing happened to me,
they don't beat me up.
- [Interviewer] They just took your money.
- Just take my money.
- [Interviewer] So they robbed you,
rather than you robbing
them, or you beating them up,
you know, it happens both ways.
I hear many stories about girls...
- Yeah. Sometimes, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Sometimes the
girls get beaten up by their..
by their customers.
But, I also hear stories
about girls tricking guys
and robbing them.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Which
is what happened to you.
- Yeah. That happened to me.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Yeah, sometimes the girls.
Yeah.
They, they told me that
they got robbed, you know?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- They're beating up.
- [Interviewer] Have you
ever been arrested for this?
- Never.
- [Interviewer] Never?
Because, I told to police that my friends,
they are living here in this area,
and they have been there.
Yeah. I never got arrested.
Like undercover cops.
No.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Never.
- [Interviewer] And how
much will you spend for it?
- How much it pay?
Depends how much money
I have in my pocket,
maybe I have 40, 50, 60.
Yeah
- [Interviewer] And you use a...
- For my tip,
the tip that I receive it is for them.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Yeah. I will get my next today.
- [Interviewer] Do you use condoms,
you're safe when you have sex?
- [Hector] Yeah. I'm safe.
I use condom always.
- [Interviewer] Have you ever
caught anything or anything?
- [Hector] No.
- [Interviewer] That's, that's good.
- [Hector] Yeah. I always condom.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And would you like to have
a relationship where you're
faithful with one woman,
you're married and committed?
Or is this more to your liking?
To have many girls at your disposal?
- [Hector] Yeah. I like that one.
- [Interviewer] You like
having the freedom to choose?
- [Hector] Freedom. Yeah.
- Right.
- [Interviewer] And do
you, do you spend time
with them or do you just
have sex and that's it?
- [Hector] I spend time sometimes.
Sometime we're going to a motel.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
so do you do this in your car or motel or?
- [Hector] Yeah. In my
car and the hotel too.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Hector] Yeah. Right.
- [Interviewer] And so, some
of the girls are really nice,
they have nice personalities,
they're beautiful girls sometimes, right?
- [Hector] Yeah. They are beautiful girls.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Hector] Always. Nice personality.
- [Hector] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] They might be addicted
to drugs sometimes though, right?
- [Hector] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah
- [Interviewer] Do you use drugs?
- [Hector] No, I don't use drugs.
That's that's my drug, you know.
(interviewer laughs)
- [Interviewer] The girls.
- [Hector] The girls on the street.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Hector] Because that is addiction.
- [Interviewer] You
think it's an addiction?
- [Hector] Yeah. It's
addiction to pick up girl.
And dangerous too.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. Very dangerous.
- [Hector] Yeah because,
you can get robbed,
or they can beat you up or,
take your car.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Hector] Anything.
- [Interviewer] Are there
any girls that you have,
like deeper relationships with,
than just picking them up for an hour and,
and dropping them off?
- I know that girls are not
only for one moment, you know,
for pleasure, because I
know they have family,
that I know they have kids.
And sometimes you see his family you know,
in different places too.
- [Interviewer] So say some of the girls,
you actually, you've met their family?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's interesting.
So you must treat the ladies nicely.
- I have to do it, yeah.
Because of personality,
they're human beings too.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I have a friend that I saw her daughter
for Christmas or for Thanksgiving day,
or for her birthday. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- And she always ask for me.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's really nice.
- [Hector] Yeah. It's really nice.
Yeah. I'm feeling good
when I go to see her daughter.
She's happy.
- [Interviewer] That's nice to hear.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What kind
of sex do you end up having?
Do you have intercourse?
Do you have oral sex?
What kind of things will you do?
- Both, the straight and oral sex.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Have you
ever had a relationship
with a woman outside of
hiring her on the street?
You ever had a girlfriend
or almost been married?
- Yeah. I marry when..
I have
one daughter and
one, two granddaughters.
Yeah. I get married with her.
- [Interviewer] Oh, so you were married?
- Yeah. Yeah.
Like a year, but I came to United State,
I get divorced.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see.
- Yeah.
She's now in New York city,
she moved to New York city.
- [Interviewer] Who, your ex wife?
- My ex wife , yeah.
- [Interviewer] So since
you've been single,
have you ever had any
other type of relationship
or just with these ladies?
- Just with these ladies.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You're satisfied.
That works for you, right?
- Yeah satisfied,
is good too.
Have been, they had been to always.
Anyway, they're humans and they
kind of help me in something
and I help them too.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
- [Interviewer] Well,
Hector, thank you so much
for talking with me,
and,
thank you for being so honest and open.
- Okay.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] So Hector,
you were here before,
but we're, I have you come back.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You're,
I heard through the grapevine,
that you kind of indulged in some
alternative sexual
behavior.
What kind of fun are you having recently?
- Oh I pick up a girl,
you know, prostitute,
from the street.
And I was drinking her pee,
and I was jerking off.
I feel good, I feel good.
- [Interviewer] So what
are you doing exactly?
You're...
Tell me exactly what happened.
(interviewer laughing)
- Yeah, we went to the hotel, you know and
we were crazy days, if
I want to drink her pee,
I said yes it's okay.
You know.
And she put
her things,
you know her pussy right here and,
she make pee, I drink it
and I was jerking off.
- [Interviewer] She pee?
- She actually pee on my face.
- [Interviewer] She peed on
your face, in the hotel room?
- Yeah in the hotel,
- [Interviewer] And, into
a cup or just on your face?
- In my mouth.
- [Interviewer] In your mouth?
- Yeah.
(interviewer laughing)
- [Interviewer] This is
something you enjoy sexually?
- Yeah. I enjoy it a lot.
- [Interviewer] What do
you think that's all about?
That's very unusual, right?
- Yeah.
- It's like a, some juice, you know?
- [Interviewer] This is
the first time for you?
- Yes. The first time for me.
It was great.
- [Interviewer] And you liked it.
- Yeah. I like it.
- [Interviewer] Something
you might do again?
- Yeah, I'm going to do it again.
(both laughing)
- [Interviewer] Alright.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What other
alternative sexual behaviors
are you possibly considering?
- After that she, she
fucked too, you know.
I smell it.
It was, it was good.
I mean...
- [Interviewer] You enjoy it?
- I enjoy it yeah.
- [Interviewer] You enjoy the taste?
- I enjoy to taste it too.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Okay Hector,
Thanks for coming in, and
and thanks for being so
wiling to talk with me.
(interviewer laughing)